we all know the feeling of trying to get
through the work we have to do to get to
the work we want to do and that's where
Watson orchestrate comes in
Watson orchestrate helps you get more
done by bringing tools and data together
to streamline tasks like never before
Watson is an extension of you that takes
on different jobs in the background
while you handle the important stuff
work that used to take hours now takes
minutes simply assign what's in the
tasks you want it to tackle like sending
emails scheduling meetings or interviews
and Expediting requests and it'll do the
rest and it will work seamlessly across
the apps and tools you already use like
Outlook LinkedIn sap success factors and
more plus the more you work together the
smarter it becomes and the more
personalized your experience gets
best of all it gives you the freedom to
focus on the work that truly matters to
you and your business
it's time to leave the busy work behind
welcome to Watson orchestrate
foreign